whoa that's a lot
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
in today's video we'll be reviewing
health and fitness creator
jasmine taylor so you can pause the
screen
or look at the description to check out
my disclaimer including a trigger
warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating
i will be talking macros and calories so
feel free to skip that portion if it
isn't supportive to your journey
and of course don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and
ring that little bell so that you never
miss out on a episode
so first little 4-1-1 on jasmine or jazz
so she is a 19-year-old content creator
originally from california
although she currently lives in los
cabos
mexico with her family she's also in her
third year school at uc berkeley which
she is doing online right now of course
due to covid so
jazz has gained a lot of popularity on
both youtube and tick tock
for her videos that are primarily
centered around healthy eating
fitness recipe ideas and recreating
other popular creators what i eat in a
day videos
she's also come heavily requested from
you guys because she
does talk a lot about intuitive eating
as well as her history with disordered
eating and amenorrhea
so today we're going to be looking at
our most recent what i eat in a week
video at the time of me filming this
as well as discussing some of the
general themes that i saw on her channel
all right let's take a look starting
with her breakfast for the week
so for breakfast jasmine usually rotates
between
a cookie dough smoothie bowl or a
blueberry smoothie bowl
both of which are always topped with her
homemade brownie granola which looks
awesome
and each sound equally delicious so
let's take a little peek
this one is my cookie dough nice cream
and then you'll see my other favorite
which is blueberry and ice cream next
of course i loaded it up with the fresh
brownie granola and i also added
raspberries which gave me fancy vibes
oh so both of these kind of like nice
cream smoothie bowls
start with a base of two bananas peanut
or almond butter
and some almond milk and she throws in
some cacao nibs for the cookie dough one
and blueberries for the blueberry one i
love that she
also tops her smoothie bowls her her
kind of nice cream with granola which
makes for a more satisfying sit-down
meal versus something that could be just
like chugged back
on the go like a smoothie in a glass
i love smoothie bowls and hers
definitely sounds really great so
we've got carbs from the banana and
healthy fats and fiber in the nut butter
i mean i would probably look to get a
little bit more protein
since a spoonful of nut butter only
provides around four grams so
for example she could throw in a higher
protein milk like soy instead of almond
add some greek yogurt if she did dairy
add a scoop of protein
powder or some silken tofu which is
totally my favorite hack right now oh
silken tofu makes the smoothest
smoothies ever even my toddler is
totally obsessed but anyway on
days she doesn't have a smoothie bowl
jasmine opts for a
classic avocado toast and eggs plus some
sauteed kale or spinach for
some micronutrient action so let's take
a look
for breakfast i made eggs and avocado
toast and i loaded the eggs with
turmeric which is anti-inflammatory
immune boosting and it just has lots of
great flavor i served it with a side of
steamed spinach
this is already a textbook balanced meal
even if
we are all kind of sick seeing it on
youtube
and instagram but it is a solid spread
with
healthy fats in the avocado fiber rich
carbs in the bread
and veg plus some protein and fats in
the eggs
love me some sweet and savory options
depending on the breakfast mood now
moving on to lunch
jasmine likes to mix it up but most
often goes for either
leftovers from her dinner from the night
before or
a big bean and rice burrito with either
some steamed veg or salad on the side
let's take a look
then you know it was time to make a
giant vegan burrito because that's one
of my favorite meals
just beans corn rice veggies and sweet
potato and an ezekiel tortilla
this is totally how i build burritos as
well my eyes are often
way bigger than well the wrap but
anyways hers looks awesome
so we've got some fiber rich carbs from
the brown rice
beans corns ezekiel tortilla we've got
some protein in the beans and healthy
fats in
the guac now as a generic recommendation
for most people who have a hard time
getting in their veg i actually think
burritos in general are a really great
way
to sneak in some extra veggies in there
i also
would say i've never actually seen an
ezekiel tortilla before
but i'm here for it so ezekiel greens
have become
more popular as of late because they're
made from a variety of sprouted whole
grains
including wheat barley millet spelt soy
beans and
lentils so sprouted bread not only means
that there are
more nutrients because the seeds have
started to germinate but
that those nutrients are also more
bioavailable
and speaking of veg on non-burrito days
she goes for a full loaded veggie salad
with lots of fiber from the greens
strawberries sweet potato corn and
cabbage
protein from some chickpeas and
nutritional yeast
and healthy fats in the olive oil
dressing and olives
i know when i'm vacationing somewhere
really hot i literally crave salads
every single day
i often can't like bring myself to have
a hot meal in the sun or
even eat like a lot of protein or heavy
carbs
but i will say that it's definitely a
lot of vegetables
i would probably not feel so good in the
gut but
if this works for jazz and it's not
displacing other important nutrients and
foods throughout the day then of course
this works for me i'm just pointing this
out because
i know a lot of my friends watching who
are just
trying to start liking vegetables might
see this and think that they could never
eat well if
eating well means having to eat this
many vegetables
and that's just not true everyone's
veggie and fiber tolerance is
so different so if you're just starting
out
do not be discouraged even just adding
like
a little bit of produce to every meal is
a really
great place to start all right moving on
to her dinners
so jasmine's dinners appear to be the
meal that she'll opt to have
a little bit of meat or fish as she does
state in her video that
while she enjoys eating mostly
plant-based
she does crave meat from time to time
and this is also how i eat most of the
time as well
so i prefer mainly vegetarian foods
but i'm also not comfortable labeling
myself or
my diet any specific way that may
discourage me from honoring those
occasional desires
for meat honestly i think that if i
did tell myself that i was vegan i would
probably just want to eat meat more
on april 4 7 30 p.m you partook a plate
of chicken parmesan
and i get that that is just my
experience with food
likely grounded in a history of
restriction and
that a lot of ethical vegans out there
do not see meat even as
food so this would never feel
restrictive to them
but anyways i'm just kind of going off
on a tangent here when all i'm trying to
say
is that i appreciate that jazz has found
a flexible
and sustainable way of eating that
ultimately feels good
to her i also want to share what she
says about
meal planning as you can see from this
week when i don't know what to eat i
just eat a source of protein with rice
and vegetables it makes getting a
balanced meal in so much easier and if
you make the protein fancy
it's super flavorful and delicious guys
i love this
friends who are avid abby's kitchen
followers know that she is talking
about the hunger crushing combination
here folks
so you know even if you don't know what
to make meals do not need to be
complicated
or fussy when you just keep that little
checklist
of fiber-rich carbs protein and
fat in mind so for jazz that typically
means that
most nights she's got some form of meat
or fish
she's got some carbs in the brown rice
or so many potatoes
and then a ton of steamed vegetables and
or salad
so let's take a look at an example it
had a couple eggs some flour
lots of spices garlic tomato sauce and
fresh rainbow chard from that box of
veggies that we had delivered when i
don't know what to eat i just need a
source of protein with rice and
vegetables
this looks so good and inherently very
well balanced
so we've got some protein and fat in the
meatloaf we've got some carbs in our
rice
and some fiber rich veg now other nights
jazz is flexible and she decides to
order food in with her family
and i'm so relieved to see that she can
approach these experiences without
anxiety or guilt let's take a look all
the kebabs there are
i don't know like no dude
you can do the short stories of
hemingway we're gonna watch avengers
we after showering jacuzz yes
so it looks like they ordered in some
kind of like mediterranean greek style
meal
and that is one of my go-to takeout
options as well
so she's getting lots of protein and fat
from the steak here
and hummus plus some fiber in the veg
now this is slightly a lower carb meal
but
i would say in the context of her day
where she's having i know like a rice
and veggie curry
for lunch and a smoothie bowl with
granola at breakfast
totally makes sense to me finally let's
talk about my
favorite food category snacks so there
are only a few days in the week that
jasmine incorporates snacks into her
days but on both of those days
they look absolutely delicious
so one day jasmine makes a coconut
pancake recipe and has a few of them for
a snack
and on the other day she recreates
another creator's chocolate avocado
pudding recipe that includes avocado
dates and cacao powder so let's take a
look
then i did an instagram collaboration
with one of my favorite models named
julia muniz and she made one of my
recipes and i made one of hers
i chose to make her five ingredient
brigadeiro which is a chocolate mousse
that's typical in brazil
the main ingredients were avocado and
dates ah this is awesome
and actually it's a snack that i've made
for my family a bunch of times as well
i actually use the chocolate mousse as
like a filling for a buckwheat breakfast
crepe
and it is so effing good
but i love that we have some fiber and
fat in the avocado
and carbs in the dates in this pudding
and the pancakes
also look super delicious and
it's also kind of nice to see just like
a normal pancake recipe for once
you know like they don't always have to
be protein pancakes or vegan pancakes
or made with some kind of almond or
coconut flour
so this recipe is actually called cheat
day pancakes
but not by jasmine by the rock who
developed the recipe
so i really appreciate that she's just
able to work the
cheat day pancakes into a normal day
flour sugar butter and all and it
doesn't turn
a normal day into a cheat day
so not only do these snacks look and
sound amazing
but they also really help her reach her
calorie goals on both of the days
that she incorporates a snack in
addition to her meals and
speaking of calories let's talk about
snacks and a trigger warning to anyone
who might find the discussion of
calories and macros to be triggering you
can skip ahead
to the time stamp on the screen when the
section is over
so based on my calculations taken from
an average of the seven days
of her video jasmine's average caloric
intake
is around 1800 calories with 1487
calories being consumed on her lowest
day
and 2108 calories on her highest
she also consumes a higher carb diet
composed of roughly 65 carbs
19 protein and 16 fat
which definitely falls in the higher
carb
moderate protein lower fat range
honestly i know people like to get hung
up on macros but
everyone has a unique ratio where they
feel best there
really isn't a one size fits all
situation having said that
in this case i would say that her fat
intake
is a little lower than i would want it
to be
seeing as most women need at least 20
percent of calories from
fat but i will speak more to that
momentarily so let's start by talking
about what i really like here
first of all i think jasmine's diet is
bright
colorful and obviously very nutritious
she eats a wide variety of fruits
veggies grains
and protein and the meals she makes are
definitely delicious looking
and also relatively easy and accessible
to pull off
she doesn't seem to be cutting out full
food groups or
talking about foods as good or bad and i
also
really appreciate that even if she
prefers to eat mainly plant-based
she's flexible to enjoy the odd bit of
meat if that is what she craves
or if that's what is available to her
she doesn't make it a big moral dilemma
you know she honors that preference and
moves on
now let's talk about some gentle
nutrition tips that might help jasmine
meet her nutrient needs so according to
my calculations and
obviously this is rough but i would say
that jasmine needs at least
2000 to 2200 calories and that's being
conservatively
low considering that she's normally very
active
she did mention that she's taking a
break from some forms of
intense exercise right now so like her
hit training
due to a knee injury but almost
daily there is some form of activity
like yoga
pilates surfing etc so while there are
days that she
is likely meeting her needs particularly
when she's got a snack in there
there are others when she's definitely
coming up short
and it's normal to see that kind of
flexibility but of course we want to
make sure that it doesn't create
a massive caloric deficit now just based
on how jasmine talks about food
i don't think she's intentionally under
eating but a lot of the foods that she
is eating
while super healthy and nutritious are
just naturally
not very energy dense they're low in fat
and
high in fiber and water which may be
really helpful for someone who's trying
to actively lose weight
but may make it challenging to meet your
nutrient needs when you're not
this is particularly relevant to jasmine
since she
is such an active young woman with a
history of disordered eating
and also of hypothalamic amenorrhea
in fact she even mentioned in one video
that her knee injury
was likely a result of over exercising
and under eating
this is a super common outcome of under
eating with
research suggesting that adolescents
with amenorrhea who diet but who don't
necessarily meet the diagnostic criteria
for
anorexia nervosa are still at
significant
risk for low bone density and
osteoporosis
anyways as i mentioned earlier jasmine
was able to achieve her caloric needs a
lot more easily
on the days that she incorporated a
snack in addition to of course
her three meals so i would probably
suggest being consistent with that snack
as often as humanly possible just to
really make sure that she's eating
enough
so that she can continue to do all the
activities that she loves
i would also say that if she was having
a hard time meeting her caloric needs
while still honoring her hunger i would
probably
focus on more nutrient dense fat rich
foods
like more avocado oils seeds and nut
butters
and to downplay the produce in her life
just just a titch
so that way she could you know get those
calories in before she feels
too full lastly let's touch on jasmine's
relationship with food
so first of all i have to commend
jasmine on how far she's
obviously come in her recovery journey
jasmine describes having struggled on
and off with an eating disorder since
she was about 14 years old
and as a result she lost her period not
once
but twice now at 19 she's really trying
to focus on
fueling her body taking rest days when
she needs them
and practicing intuitive eating so that
is a huge
accomplishment for jasmine and i have no
doubt that it was not
easy to get through i also appreciate
that she's typically an
ally in debunking a lot of wellness bs
in her q a video discussing her fitness
journey
and her relationship with exercise jazz
says this you're only going to get abs
if you can lower the body fat on your
stomach and there's no way to spot
reduce fat
no exercise is gonna cause targeted fat
loss in a specific area you can't decide
where to lose that fat because
scientifically our bodies don't work
like that gotta focus on fat loss eating
at a caloric deficit so this whole idea
that you can
spot reduce belly fat really needs to
die can you accomplish this with lipo
yeah but there is no magical cocktail of
foods and exercises that will sculpt
your body
to look like kim k's ultimately how and
where you lose weight
just comes down to general weight and
fat loss like she says
hormones age sex and also your genetics
i also want to comment on this so yeah i
would say that there's no
right reason to start a healthy
lifestyle because of course wanting to
look a certain way
is totally fine you do you but just know
that how you feel
is so much more important than looking
at certain ways whether you're looking
to improve your health
status fitness energy or just look a
certain way
i think all intentions for making
changes to your lifestyle are valid
and of course should be respected jazz
also addresses the topic of
cheat day so let's take a look and as
for cheat days i don't really like that
term because it kind of implies like a
negative connotation because like
cheating you know that sounds bad but
when it comes to healthy lifestyle you
shouldn't see treating yourself as cheat
days that's why i like to think of it as
like a treat day okay so
jasmine thinks the idea of cheating has
a negative connotation so she prefers
the term
treat day instead and while i think we
can probably do without
the need to make any one day a full out
treat fest i think treat is a more
positive step
in the right direction i guess having
said that
it still gives power to said treat foods
you know in my house we actually banned
the word treat no one says it
and i think my son actually finally
forgot about the word as well
we just call the foods what they are
right like cookies and popsicles or
chocolate or whatever
i guess to me i just don't want him to
put the sweet foods on a pedestal
and see them as something that he needs
to obsess over
and hold out for
but bottom line in my opinion if we
really want to move towards
food freedom we don't want to just
change our
language we also need to change our
mentality
and that may mean stepping outside of
these arbitrary rules
of when you can have a treat so that we
don't need to
pack them all into one epic day of
eating
just to go back to eating clean the next
day
i'm not suggesting jasmine is
necessarily doing this
she seems pretty consistent in her
patterns but
this is typically what we see with the
whole
cheat day mentality so these are things
that i generally agree with jazz on
but i also want to unpack a few of her
other statements in the context of her
relationship with food
so first jasmine says that she tries to
eat healthy
95 of the time meaning no added sugar
or processed food and that she treats
herself
five percent of the time so this is the
whole treat day cheat day
situation while this might work fine for
her
i would say that this ratio is probably
unrealistic and also difficult to
maintain
for most folks out there just trying to
keep a healthy diet also as a dietitian
i would strongly advise against
leaning on any of these pseudo
guidelines which
are basically just sugar-coated rules
not to mention 95 healthy eating and
avoiding any processed foods or added
sugar
feels like a pretty strict rule to me
especially for somebody in or recently
out of recovery
we also don't need to demonize processed
foods here
i mean don't forget that a lot of the
nutritional benefits and food safety
in our food system comes from food
processing
we wouldn't have pasteurized milk or
yogurt
frozen produce protein powder or any of
your vegan non-dairy alternatives
without food processing so i would just
love to see
influencers stop the fear-mongering
around all processed food
processed foods can be really healthy
options
and even ultra processed foods are fine
in moderation
i also want to unpack a few of jasmine's
statements
about intuitive eating let's take a look
when it comes to losing weight
you gotta eat in a caloric deficit try
tracking your meals and your calories
for just two to three days so you can
see what portions work for you based on
those portions try eating intuitively
which is basically where you just listen
to your hunger cues and listen to your
body
you'll definitely get the hang of it and
basically it's all about the portions
you eat
okay so basically she's suggesting that
you track your calories and macros for a
few days
before transitioning into intuitive
eating so that you know
how much you should be eating so i see a
lot of influencers
talking about intuitive eating like it's
something that you can do
only once you've dieted or restricted
long enough to kind of train your brain
in
such a way to maintain such diet or way
of eating
intuitively i'm not suggesting that this
is exactly what jazz is saying
but it is a common sentiment so i
thought a lot about this
over the past few months first of all i
used to be really annoyed by influencers
co-opting the term intuitive eating to
basically become solely synonymous with
the hunger fullness diet
everyone just focuses on the idea that
intuitive eating is
just eat when you're hungry stop when
you're full but
i know now that intuitive eating is kind
of a higher level concept so
i don't blame anyone for not fully
understanding it
in all of its nuanced ways intuitive
eating is
actually a mind-body framework that just
isn't compatible with portion control or
calorie counting
as it was originally conceptualized i
know this is just semantics but
i pointed out because if intuitive
eating is being celebrated as
the ultimate state of food freedom
kicking off your journey with caloric
tracking or portion control isn't going
to get you there necessarily
this is only really creating a template
that you can safely
stay within and as long as you're not
hungry
you think that you're free but this
framework
still lacks flexibility i want to
reiterate that i don't think intuitive
eating in its entirety
is for everyone a lot of us do need
structure
and that is totally fine so that might
mean learning a bit about different
macros
and how they make you feel and perform
it might mean
reading some nutrition labels to see
where sources of added sugar or salt or
saturated fat
lies in your favorite foods and then
making choices
of how often you want to include said
foods
and i also think that there's room for
looking at your portions too
and even in a way that is fully
compatible with intuitive eating
so for example maybe you want to see how
a bowl of cereal
holds you in terms of your fullness so
you measure out a cup of cheerios and
see how that goes
well it turns out that you discover a
cup of cheerios maybe isn't enough for
you
so the next day you'll know you need
about a cup and a half
or maybe you need to pair it with an egg
or it could be the opposite
and you want to ensure that you're not
just wasting food day after day after
day
so maybe you put a half a cup of rice on
your plate and you see how that feels
before you add more and this is just
data
so over time once you've collected
enough data on the approximate amounts
of food
needed to satisfy you in different
scenarios
you can more accurately and
appropriately serve yourself your food
the key to keeping this compatible with
intuitive eating is that
a your personalized data is informing
said portion not some external diet rule
b there is no moral association
with the portions so you don't feel
shame if you need to have
more than you think you should have and
c
you allow yourself to have more or less
food
completely guilt-free as needed knowing
that even though a cup of oatmeal is
maybe usually enough to get you through
to lunch
some days you might also just need a
snack
so hopefully that clarifies how we can
actually use things like
portion knowledge and still work towards
having
an intuitive relationship with food
so in conclusion i really like jasmine's
channel
and her general message that healthy
eating and
exercising is supposed to feel good
she seems to have made significant
progress in her outlook on food and her
body
and i'm hopeful that she can continue to
enhance her food flexibility
and food freedom to find a way of eating
that
she can really maintain long term and
that is it for today's video folks
if you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below on
who you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel i will see you
next time on abby's kitchen
bye and for more great videos like this
check out the link right here
you